dieser Straße war immer so lebendig
[Musik]
wir haben uns hier getroffen wenn wir
unterwegs zur Kirche waren oder auf dem
Weg zum Einkaufen
und jetzt ist das alles hier kaputt
[Musik]
insca vor den Toren können die Menschen
nicht fassen was der Krieg aus ihrem Ort
gemacht hat
[Musik]
bis zum Abzug der Russen vor wenigen
Tagen war hier die Front russische
Soldaten hatten das Sagen ließen
niemanden rein oder raus
Familien wurden auseinandergerissen
jetzt ist die Wiedersehensfreude groß
Anna ihre 15-jährige Tochter Olga und
die Nachbarn können nicht glauben dass
die schlimme Zeit vorbei ist das Erlebte
lässt sie so schnell nicht los sie
kochen Tee bereiten Brot und
eingemachtes sie wollen uns erzählen was
sie erlebt hatten als der Krieg das kam
meine Tochter hatte Panikattacken sie
konnte zwei Wochen lang nichts essen ich
versuchte sie zu beruhigen dass wir doch
nicht alleine sind und das trotz allem
hier sogar Babys geboren werden
in dieser schlimmen Situation haben wir
Nachbarn fest zusammengehalten jeden
Morgen haben wir uns alle über die
Straße hinweg zugewunken und gerufen
dass wir noch am Leben sind
acht Monate lang haben sie Todesängste
durchgestanden sie waren trotz strikt im
Verbots immer wieder heimlich mit dem
Handy online und sie haben Kontrollen
und Hausdurchsuchungen über sich ergehen
lassen bis sie Russen auf einmal weg
waren
die haben sich mitten in der Nacht
heimlich verzogen ich bin dann
aufgewacht als mein Nachbar rief die Ort
sind weg wir sind dann zum Marktplatz
gelaufen wo unsere Soldaten schon ankam
jeder winkte ihn zu viele weinten manche
sagten auf die Knie das war sehr
emotional
[Musik]
einstmals stolze Bürger sind sie jetzt
degradiert zu Bittstellern an einem
Laster voller Kohlköpfe es ist eine
erste Hilfe von außen im Kampf gegen den
Hunger
der Ort mit einsmals 12.000 Einwohnern
erlebt die Stunde Null erstmals seit
Monaten werden jetzt endlich wieder
Renten in ukrainischer Währung
ausgezahlt improvisiert aus einem Auto
heraus in den Geschäften gibt es dafür
nichts zu kaufen und so schlägt die
Stunde der Schwarzmarkthändler am
Straßenrand
ein paar Meter weiter kehrt als erste
ukrainische Behörde die Polizei
zurücklassen die Beamten beziehen eine
neue Wache die alte haben die Russen in
die Luft gesprengt funktioniert wir
müssen hier so schnell wie möglich für
Ordnung sorgen und das Vertrauen der
Menschen gewinnen denn viele stehen
immer noch unter Schock
beim Einmarsch der Russen waren die
Polizisten bis zum letzten Moment auf
ihrem Posten geblieben bevor sie sich
über die Felder in Sicherheit gebracht
hatten das verschafft ihnen jetzt
genauso Respekt wie ihr Bemühen den Ort
von russischen Sprengfallen zu befreien
unsere Polizei beseitigt auch die Minen
das ist sehr gefährlich erst vor ein
paar Tagen ist der Chef unserer
entschärfungseinheit schwer verletzt
worden
ein großer Teil der Gegend hier ist
anna hat Glück ihr kleiner Gemüsegarten
hinter dem Haus bliebte schon von Minen
oder gefährlichen Blindgängern was sie
hier angebaut hatte brachte sie und ihre
Tochter über den Sommer Trinkwasser
müssen sie mühsam aus dem Brunnen nach
oben kurbeln die Leitungen für Strom und
Wasser sind noch nicht repariert
wer sich nicht selbst versorgen kann
muss an der Schule Schlange stehen für
Hilfspakete bis zum Krieg hat auch Olga
hier gelernt
jetzt in dieser boler ich weiß noch
genau am 22 Februar war mir schlecht und
ich bin nach Hause gegangen kurz danach
hat die russische Invasion begonnen und
die Schule wurde geschlossen alle
blieben zu Hause oder im Keller
die Russen starteten eigenen
Schulunterricht wollten die Kinder nach
ihrem Lehrplan ausbilden den russischen
Blick auf die Welt vermitteln Eltern
drohten Strafen wenn sie sich dem
widersetzen
die Russen wollten mir mein Kind
wegnehmen wenn ich Olga nicht in deren
Schule schicken würde
Online-Unterricht mit unserer Schule
wollten sie nicht zulassen sie sprachen
auch von hohen Geldstrafen ich sagte der
Online-Unterricht hat hier immer gut
funktioniert bis ihr das Internet
abgestellt habt Olga wollte nicht nach
dem russischen Lehrplan lernen
der russische Abzug machte Schluss mit
diesem umerziehungsversuch anna hat aber
Angst dass Krieg und Besatzung noch
lange nachwirken werden
das Schwerste ist in diesem Krieg bei
all diesem Hass menschlich zu bleiben
dass sich die Menschen bemühen mit
anderen freundlich höflich und liebevoll
umzugehen ganz wichtig ist dass wir uns
gegenseitig helfen das geht in all
diesem Hass aber unter wir sehen ja wie
die Menschen jetzt reden und kämpfen
aber halten sie zusammen haben immer
daran geglaubt dass die schwere Zeit
vorübergeht jetzt ist es soweit und
diese Erfahrung lässt sie fest daran
glauben dass die Ukraine überlebt